well first off it's a mistake to think
that if you didn't have this contest
there wouldn't be a risk there's always
a risk in elections when I first ran
having been appointed to the Senate I
was 36 percentage points behind in the
public opinion polls I'll never forget
it these are the kinds of things that
stick in your mind the headlines said he
has no chance to win well I won the
election by a big margin so anybody who
says to you whoa this was this as a sure
thing that's a sure thing in my in my
mind that's completely wrong any
election can be won any can be lost any
candidate can win any candidate could
lose depending upon what happened so
let's remove the central premise of the
question that if you didn't have a
contest the Democrats would be sure to
win to me that's just not true so then
you argue well yes corset they can be
hurt if you have a primary the benefit
is you get a lot of publicity there's a
lot of focus on them the downside is
that the polls show that substantial
numbers of clinton voters wouldn't vote
for obama in the fall if he got the
nomination and the reverse but over time
I think that a very large number of them
will come around because the alternative
I think will be worse that is the
election of Senator McCain and a
Republican to the presidency and
particularly since you consider that in
many respects the policies being pursued
would be those of the current
administration which certainly anybody
who's voted for Obama or Clinton and in
the primaries wouldn't be supporting so
a lot will depend upon how the candidate
who doesn't get the nomination handles
it I think I think both of them are so
committed to the principles that they're
talking about to the democratic party
that they will help
to heal the wounds once this competitive
process is over difficult as that can be
because personal ambition and I say that
in a positive not a pejorative sense
plays a very large role in all of this
of course that they'll come around and
that the the democratic candidate will
prevail in the fall but there's no such
thing as a sure thing
ha